el paisaje nocturno en la provincia de
córdoba es aterrador líneas de fuego se
apoderan del paisaje destruyendo la
vegetación de 11 provincias argentinas
en total según informó el servicio
nacional del manejo del fuego
y actualmente en la provincia están tres
cuatro o cinco focos activos ahora que
es verne
y estar viviendo lo que está lo que está
pasando es increíble en la sierra la
cantidad de hectáreas que se están
quemando en los últimos 10 días los
incendios han destruido más de 16.000
hectáreas en córdoba las condiciones se
atribuyen a los fuertes vientos y la
sequía de la tierra la situación es
igual en paraguay país vecino donde el
congreso declaró la emergencia nacional
a raíz de los incendios en la región del
chaco que han destruido vastas franjas
de bosque seco
más al norte los efectos devastadores
del fuego también se sienten en brasil
desde enero de este año la amazonía de
este país es víctima de cientos de
incendios así como el humedal el
pantanal que comparten brasil paraguay y
bolivia mientras que la selva amazónica
experimenta su peor racha de incendios
en 10 años el presidente ya ir bolsonaro
se comprometió a protegerla sin embargo
su discurso es incoherente ya que en
días pasados negó ante la comunidad
internacional los efectos del cambio
climático
la intensidad del calor también ha hecho
de las suyas en bolivia el fuego
destruido más de un millón de hectáreas
de bosques y pastizales en las regiones
norte y centro del país
hasta el momento en el área afectada son
339 mil hectáreas ya correspondiente a
26 incendios activos ubicados en el
departamento de santa cruz y el beni
gracias a las lluvias el fuego está
ahora bajo control
[Aplausos]